this big pink building has an unusual  name welcome to the green citadel  located in the central german city of  mugdeburg is an unusually bright complex  of 55 residential apartments shops cafes  a hotel and a preschool  the green citadel took two years to  complete and was one of the first  pre-fabricated slab buildings  constructed in germany the bright pink  contrasts with the roof which during the  warmer seasons is an entirely green  garden  no two pillars or doors are the same  within the complex each is uniquely  shaped or mosaic  created by the late austrian architect  friedan wright underwater it was his  last work before he passed in his own  words he describes the place as an oasis  for humanity and nature in a sea of  rational houses  [Music]  [Music]  you